of gorillas hey philip thanks for thanks
for having me yeah i mean first question
obvious question i mean you founded your
company in germany but you're turkish
right yes yes i'm coming from turkey
istanbul
when did you come to germany
i mean first time i came to germany it
was it was quite young um i came to
i came to visit my aunt she was a
professor here i was like 10 years old
like that times i just bought my first
first gameboy
first gameboy and uh but essentially
essentially when i came the last time it
was two years ago
um two years ago i moved here
and
like since then i'm living in berlin and
how come berlin
how come germany
yeah so to be honest i came to germany i
came to berlin
six or seven years ago to build a
venture yeah
and i applied to rocket internet and
they didn't reply me then i applied to
recognition again didn't reply me so six
times i did this in one month
and then i said okay
it's not gonna work probably and as i
wrote my instagram istanbul berlin at
some point i'm gonna come back and uh
yeah and six years later i said in my in
my head it was always like berlin i'm
gonna go to berlin build my venture so
now we're here yeah okay okay and um
so you see but when you first came here
it wasn't for gorillaz it was basically
you wanted to like start something but
you didn't know exactly what
um
to be honest to be honest when you when
you're living in istanbul and when you
make your way out um
what you want to do is not the first
choice so you just you just first want
to make your way and after that
you know like once you have the legal
and admin stuff
in place then you shift to what you do
and this is exactly what i did first
built a venture for rocket internet uh
b2b so finally they accepted you then
yes yes yes exactly and
in istanbul before you came here you you
studied mechatronics right you're like
an engineer by trade exactly exactly i i
mean i'm a mechatronics engineer
and i took significant time to shift
from mechatronics to what i really want
to do here um and and i mean also
when i talked to you before the podcast
i learned that you you played like water
polo on the national level you were the
captain of the turkish national team so
you're like an athlete as well
yeah like philip if
if as i told you also before the before
the podcast if you know three things
about me is one is i'm madly in love
with bikes and second i'm i'm in love
with team sports yeah um and third thing
is i love consumer businesses so this is
more or less there's more or less like
three things about me
and um
the bike love is is is so big that it's
not only like google is obviously a bike
based business you're like delivering by
bike yeah but also like you rode your
bike from from istanbul to to china once
yeah this is yeah this is this was one
of the best things i've ever done in my
life
but bike life by bike bike love is not
only also the china trip you know um
i mean
i'm madly now with bikes when i came to
germany i had 100 euros 88 euros first
day i bought a bike i have a bike tattoo
you know like
i carry my bike all around and
and bike love is
is is something that that kind of
touched me across across my life and i
think i think now that we changed this
second biggest consumer spend on two
wheels it feels super special okay okay
and um and i mean so those three pillars
of your of your life are also like
included in gorillas like obviously the
bikes and yeah and i mean um
you told me about like your warehouses
and yeah the warehouses are basically
your locker rooms you have like loud
techno music in the warehouses
yeah yeah definitely definitely so so
one thing i enjoyed while playing
waterfall is the locker rooms it's uh
like
in before the game it's all about
motivation it's all about passion it's
all about commitment and the team and
after the after the game it's more like
celebration and
and
very like very relaxed and sentimental
feelings so this is exactly what i see
also in our in our warehouses now
uh now we have this decentralized
warehouses everyone you know goes for
the same goal and i just i just love it
you know i just love it it's um it's
super special you entered the warehouse
like techno music playing uh there's
people are shouting like this is my
order hey give me my order didn't you
put the banana inside you know this
i mean it's super super special
environments i would say how old are you
today today today i am
so i'm 32 32 yeah
and you also like you fit in like a
couple years of consulting right you
worked as a consultant in istanbul as
well right
yes yes yes so
i i mean
so basically
basically i i built my first venture and
after that i said okay
if i want to build a venture and you
know raise some funds this is this is
this was my hypothesis by then i need to
have some reputation some form of
reputation
and especially if i want to do this in
europe
so
so i i told myself okay khan you know
like you either be an entrepreneur or
do something that will take you to
entrepreneurship and at that moment i
realized consulting is a very good
option to do this
um
it's a very good option to do this and
uh and at that point i jumped into bain
and company uh three years three three
three possibly correct years i would say
correctly
now that i see you and i know you it
seems like a strange thing like you had
bane you must have had some trouble
there yeah i mean you should ask you
should ask the partners it's um
i mean it was
to be honest i'm someone who cannot be
politic politically correct just because
the environment is politically correct
and
and this
this sometimes gave tough times uh to to
to the to the team but overall overall
it was quite successful so three years
full of implementation yeah we i didn't
do so much so many slides
that that's that's why that's why uh our
pitch deck is not the fanciest one but
you know just the pragmatic ones
first half first off i built with a
great team one of the
one of the
best loyalty programs globally i would
say between a turkish bank and between
turkish airlines so we built this credit
card the retail partnerships the app
so it was like it was it was great
project with full of implementation and
data
um the second it was successful so that
bain tell bain told me that okay you
know like now you can do
uh you can do some entrepreneurial
projects and the rest so second half one
and a half years it was all about moving
from conglomerate to conglomerate and uh
building small startups
but then then you came to berlin and
when you finally left bain and he came
to berlin and did you already have this
idea of gorillas with you i mean i know
there's a that's a turkish
version of of gorillas
get here
in my turkish it's getting
did you already carry that in your head
or like what brought you to finally
found cabela's
i mean
like multiple things come together uh
when for for gorilla so i mean i when i
was when i came to berlin i i in my head
i knew that i was going to build a
venture but there were two ideas in my
head and
one was one was the one was gorillas and
what what what makes me
so what what makes me want to build
gorillas is basically three things first
i'm in love with the service culture
yeah so what i mean by that is imagine
you go to you go to a turkish restaurant
yeah
and
you order cigarette
first of all they bring you the
cigarette but the the most importantly
when you ask for it you know someone
goes to this someone goes to the kiosk
they get they get the cigarette they
open the pack uh they you know they put
on a on in for on a on a nice plate you
know they showcase you this uh this this
cigarette pack and
and
this is not only in this example like in
every part of the culture there's
service culture and i quite like it and
this is this was something uh that that
i was seeking
in each time that i was in europe
um especially northern europe and and
western europe so the service culture is
not the same turkey has a much more
service-oriented culture
yeah i mean yes i think i think the i
think how how people approach the
service is a bit different uh i mean
this has multiple reasons in my point of
view one is one might be uh
yeah one one might be
very much in the culture itself one
might be um
one might be like unfortunately
unfortunate to say but one might be
income disparity so
so there's there's a lot of there's a
lot of um
yeah why that's happening yeah why
that's happening but but
very very importantly this service
culture service culture is something
that something that i think is very
beautiful uh so so this is this is one
thing that
i wanted to bring to you to europe or
you know mature markets i would say
and
second second thing is
as you told there was there was
comparable models in turkey um not only
not only gator but i mean if you think
about this if you think about this when
i when i was a little kid yeah
uh how how we were doing our groceries i
tell you my mom was opening the window
shouting
two breads
one you know eggs and blah and then the
kiosk the kiosk in front of us they were
just bringing the products my mom was um
releasing one basket from the window and
it was ten minutes you know the stamina
so this is actually how we reach our
essential needs was quite pragmatic and
quite human um so so this would i think
this is i think this is like the
fundamental of fundamental of the
service culture so but like
let's let's try to understand how it
started here i mean it's not long time
ago it was like you came here 2019 yeah
and then you worked for rocket again for
like only a couple months right yeah
yeah in the global food group yeah b2b
food group we should be food group okay
and then you finally decided okay you
didn't have much money at the time you
were like basically broke
definitely i'm still i'm still a bit bro
exactly i was um
yeah so but didn't they i mean you must
have made some money at bain and at
rocket they pay they pay okay right yeah
to be honest
there's a turkey saying
when it flows you need to save
and i never had a feeling that it flows
in so
i didn't say yeah because because if the
moment in my point of view if you even
if you're in the most well-paid job
you're still in a well-paid job and you
don't really i mean you help creating
the value but you don't create financial
value for your personal funds in my
point of view so
so that's why i said i never had i never
wanted to save i just i just want to
invest in myself and my life and you
know so what was it like then like end
of 2019 so a couple months before corona
started you decided to
to give it a try i mean and the story is
apparently that that you have started
google i mean the company wasn't called
google at the time it was called what
was their first name i tell you the
story of phil
exactly sorry so
so
i came to germany with my wife yeah um
and
first we were super happy first we were
super happy that we're here but then we
realized that
it's gonna take a while until we get the
same standards in turkey and and we we
were literally
quite broke yeah i mean
constantly living in the minus single
income
so we were
we were um
we were exploring how we can how we can
decrease our costs yeah
um
and
and actually two things happened two
things happened uh one is well one is
about like do you ask me the story how i
built gorillas this is the exact story
so
one day we are coming from the grocery
store uh with my with my wife and we
were walking and we were thinking oh man
we spent like so much so much money like
this time and how are we gonna do this
how are we gonna handle this
and
and i was meanwhile i was thinking about
this model you know like i need to i
need to build i need to build regardless
i need to build gorillas and what exact
same time that we
that we
were thinking what to do next or how do
we you know cut our expenses
never happened to me in my life i never
found money on the street never happened
to me in my life this it was windy and
this five euro bill out of nowhere it
just
stick to my leg and it stayed there for
like one second or so
one second is actually quite a lot when
you know something like this happens and
i i'm a superstitious person and
i said oh man like if this is not a sign
what's the sign and i looked at my wife
i said we now go to we now go to our
place we empty the living room we built
the shelves get the products from metro
and then i just do this
so
we literally with all like the moment we
get inside of our house
i mean she thought that i'm crazy she
still thinks that i'm crazy
she has a point and she knows me very
well and but i just begin from that
moment on i i never stopped until then
so you walked home like in a regular
everyday situation you found money on
the street you took this as a sign
then you came back to your apartment and
you and you created a warehouse in your
apartment and then how did like then
you've built your first website and how
did you find your first customers yeah
so
so of course meanwhile i i said i've
worked on that so what i did is while
i'm building the shelves you know
from ob got the products from metro
i called my friend from poland and uh i
told him
man there's something crazy uh yeah like
i have a i have a crazy idea and you
need to support it and it's gonna be big
and when it's gonna be big uh you're
gonna you're gonna be happy that you you
helped me at the moment he said oh okay
what do you want i he he's doing
marketplaces he's he's
uh he's building marketplaces
but but super super basic marketplaces
and i told him just give me one
marketplace
have a natural design you select one and
i'm gonna change the domain i'm gonna
change the product pictures and after
that i'm going to use it so yeah so he
gave you like a pre-developed
marketplace like a software for that and
that was your first uh
exactly exactly so what was the company
called at the time yeah get goodies
get
and then you put all the
supermarket products on this marketplace
and then how did you like get traffic on
this
so
my wife helped me a lot on this one so
what i did is
i prepared
flyers that like flyer designs and i uh
posted them on a4 papers you know like
four four flyers on one eight f4 paper
and
i had hundred
of 25 pages and then i cut them and i
said okay
now let's do this you know let's uh
let's put them inside of the mailboxes
i mean and so you walk around the
neighborhood and put them in the mailbox
yourself exactly it's my apartment next
door the door
you know across the street
so it worked like a charm you know 400
400 uh
you know like what's the conversion rate
to the two percent or so i heard in food
delivery when you fly it i mean we had
10 percent conversion so so you like
let's say that you had like r4 papers
you cut them out that you one paper did
gave you four flyers exactly and how
many flies did you have 25 200 250. yeah
so in total hundreds of
fliers 100 flyers and 10 replied to you
and wanted to order food with you yeah i
they so what what they
saw first of all i didn't have a
functioning website i didn't have the
checkout
so
so because i just cloned one thing and
put my products there
i check i checked people on google
analytics you know like first they
entered they spent a little bit time
they added products and then they they
wanted to go check out they want but i
didn't have a checkout so that's why
that's why some of them converted to
cash payments but many of them i
realized that they want to go to you
know credit card payment and paypal
payment so that's why i said okay this
is going to convert it's going to
convert okay and then then you deliver
them the food yourself and you bought
the food at river or beethoven um yeah
so in the beginning in the beginning it
was metro
but then from left and right i collected
i collected the goods so
how it happened is
in the beginning
i said okay what i'm gonna what i'm
gonna uh
put in inside of the store yeah
and i said okay let me look at some
products you know some other products
some some online shops and i have a few
then i have a feeling when i looked at
these other shops
i realized that like there are way too
many things
and then i said okay like i need to
prioritize this thing
i i got these categories yeah and the
sub categories what i mean by that is
drinks i didn't take drinks i took uh
soft drinks i didn't even take soft
drinks but took and for example energy
drinks yeah or like uh
bo soft drinks
so i had like a list of
60 to 70
um 60 to 70
um
sub sub categories
i took this and i went to the i went to
the street i found like 40 45 people and
i made a whatsapp group from from these
people so there were like 10 20 people
that i know and 230 people that i don't
know i just met you know
and i asked them i told them look you
know we're gonna do something special
here and you're gonna be that like the
his history you're gonna be history for
for something and
some of them bought some of them didn't
buy um but i asked them essentially two
questions
so
first question is
from these sub categories which one
would you buy
from gorillaz by then get goodies second
question is what would be your
purchasing criteria so
how would you decide what to buy yeah
first answer
directly merged
same people all people wanted to buy
same things similar things and all
people didn't want to buy
similar things so this kind of gave me
an understanding of which products i
should list
in in the platform the second question
is a very interesting question how would
you buy things yeah and what would be
your purchasing criteria
i mean if you think about this there are
a couple of person criteria one one
might be price you know you want the
cheapest one one might be brand you want
a certain brand one might be right size
and packaging so
there was a consistent
direction of the answers or consistent
bucketing of these answers in these
categories what i mean by that
you want to buy trash bag yeah
if you go to a supermarket
you you see tons of trash bags like it's
like two like one complete aisle you
know that aisle um
shelf
but essentially
people want to have the right size they
don't care about you know brand they
don't care about
they don't care about the color
what they care about is i want 10 liter
20 20 liter 35 liter 60 liter bag and i
want a bee option for this you know like
a
environmentally healthy option
so that's why you can actually have six
products there six six skus there and
you can close it you don't need a huge
aisle
but when it comes to beer
then people begin saying
i want uh i want heineken i want abrogia
i want uh i love my local beer shop so
there you see that you cannot only have
the sizes you need to have like
different brands so that's why we went
wider but your market research was
basically whatsapp group that you
created from people on the street yeah
yeah i think i think i love those
searches so this is at main we did many
of them and it works it works like a
chart and it's and it's more personal i
love it and and i mean
how did you like then
turn this marketplace that you like got
from your polish friend
into like the app that we know today i
mean who built this i mean who gave you
the first like help that technically
you're not a developer no no i didn't
have a developer but i met the i think
the best person so it was quite lucky
that
i met him so
ronnie shibley our current cto
was building the exact same business
in lebanon
so
while i was searching for our product
partner i took i took a deep breath and
i searched for the exact
exact
same product i mean i didn't search for
a marketplace i didn't search for a
prototype that i that can be customized
i search for someone who i can
communicate well with or i understand
myself we have the same values and
they built the exact same business so
ronnie
apparently i didn't know him by then but
i heard that there's someone in lebanon
who's doing the exact same i mean how
did you find him on linkedin or how did
you find him so
basically
first first
first i saw i found the i found the
company yes what's it called lebanon
knock knock knock knock yeah then
then
second thing was to find
who was behind it and by and there i
realized that there's someone
who who's my who's my second second uh
circle
knows him so he was my third third
network so uh so i reached i reached uh
ralph a common friend of ours
and
and basically uh basically i reached
them and after that we clicked from the
very first day
first guy from lebanon he lived in byron
at the time yeah yeah he's um he was he
was living in he was he was living in
beirut
um
and man what like
first we begin as you know customer and
partner so like you're doing hey i want
this uh like this is my design i want to
do it this way i don't like this you
know to i cannot release this but then i
realized that like this guy is also
crazy like me he's like we are talking
at 1 32
to like in the night he's waking up he's
going to a room and he's talking to me
and and we really you know sometimes we
get heated sometimes we celebrate like
it's full of emotions
and
and at that point i decided to put alarm
clock for every day at six o'clock in
the morning no no in the evening
in the evening and at six o'clock for
three months i called him i told him
ronnie you should join us
ronnie look man like believe in me this
is crazy amazing team you should join us
so at the end of the end of this 90 days
and one day he called me at he didn't
call me at six but he called me and he
said that khan you know what you know
i'm coming there and then he moved to
berlin yeah yeah he more than him and
how did you pay him i mean like the
first few months that he like built your
app for you from byron um
how did you pay him
yeah
so when i decided that i'm going all in
i mean n26 was giving me minus 8k
in my car and i was at minus 5k
and
minus 2.5 k
i paid
for for one uh
for one very spectacular moment uh in my
life so i can get into this later so i
had essentially 500 euros
so
when ronnie told me you know like this
is these are the costs and we have this
these are the initial setup costs and
you know it's more or less this much
it's
i mean high five digits
i told him
no no no no
500 euros man
500 euros i'm going all in i'm gonna
make this product you know like i'm
gonna make this product
like go crazy with a perfect team around
it you know like we're gonna live with
this product and then you're gonna be
proud that your platform as a service
company will be well known in europe so
this is how we do it
and we negotiated and you know like uh
in lebanon you negotiate quite tough uh
so
we said okay let's give it a try and i
like you know i should appreciate that
his trust and belief because like he had
no reason to do it and and he did it and
i think it was a it was a good decision
so so the first month you you basically
built a company with no money i mean you
had your friend in poland who gave you
the first marketplace you had the guy
lebanon who
who you gave 500 euros for the for the
app yeah and and and the merchandise i
mean the products you bought them on
with your disc with your with your like
credits on index and 26
at river and metro and then we saw them
in your neighborhood
not not not really because i ran out of
money after after i talked to ronnie
because i gave
because you know i gave everything to
him and then i said okay now we need to
we need to make this for real you know
we need to rent a place we need to get
some products so how can i do it
i mean at that point i called my mom i
seriously remember
so i
so basically i told her mom you know
what
i raised the money i i got the fancy
finally it's happening but there's
nothing you know everyone says no every
single day
a little bit every single day i get at
least 10 to 20 knows at those times oh
you were already pitching at the time
revenue i began pitching i have two vcs
two or two angels most of time and i'm
you know like i'm seeing like the
reaction from the market man
everyone's laughing like i mean
they're listening to me and they're
laughing while they're listening but you
know in a teasing way and i said okay so
i need to get this money in i need to
get this running i called my mom told
her
you know mom i i raised the money i
raised the money this is gonna be big
i'm doing this
but
i need to pay the lawyers you know
i need to pay the lawyers like otherwise
i cannot get the money and uh
she i think she understood that you know
it's not that straightforward but she
gave you compliments she gave me she
gave me four thousand and also my
co-founder put four thousand and so it's
8 000 euros
and we said okay now we ranked the first
place
we began biking we looked around so we
saw we were about to share a 30 meter
square place with a fashion designer and
said no man like he's gonna go crazy we
cannot get this place and we found a
place at bansgastrasse
yeah our first uh heaven heaven it's a
amazing place so uh
so we want to rent the place calcium
plus the first rent is more than 8 000
euros
what are you gonna do
uh
so they don't let me they like the
company doesn't have credit history they
don't they want us like upfront payment
so
my co-founder uh
find a guarantor you know if something
so we try to we try to
get a
we try to get a position that we don't
pay calcium and we just you know do the
upfront payment
and uh yeah so somehow we you know we
talked we talked to the guys and we said
okay first month's rent we pay monthly
and we just paid the first month's rent
but i mean like after some pitching to
angels finally you found also found a
business angel that believed in you yeah
the first people who wouldn't laugh at
us was
christopher meyer and famous business
angel in berlin yeah yeah he's i mean
we are still we're still talking you
know on a on a frequent basis actually
after after here i'm gonna go and meet
him
um
i mean he was he was spectacular and i
think he who he was asking uh you know
he was asking
questions that's pushing me in the
beginning but he understood that i'm not
i'm not joking i mean i see this i see i
see it i see where it's going and uh he
believed in me i'm very thankful for
that and then and then he invest a
couple hundred thousand
yeah so
so in the beginning it was for the seven
digit investment a low level seven digit
um
uh of course there were a couple of
angels also uh
in the in the game
uh and then yeah and then it just just
took it and i mean like before we get
into the metrics because i mean at first
glance the model doesn't look very
very interesting i mean you you deliver
like products from the supermarket to
somebody's house very individually so
you ask like how is this gonna ever
gonna be profitable you you promised to
be there in 10 minutes
so so it looks like this is not a model
that um
that can work but before we get into
this um like when did you switch to the
name gorillaz and who had this genius
idea i mean it's it's a fantastic name
i love the name i love the name so
first of all i was
i was never confident with get goodies
yeah it was there were trademark issues
they were
there were many things around his name
and and also i wasn't super happy with
it you know what's get goodies
so i was in my in my head i was thinking
you know i was thinking and asking some
people in the creative domain like what
do you think this kind of a business
should be named
and they were all saying very similar
things grocery is about trust grocery is
about freshness groceries about
green and
you know like it's about
it's about building this trust
i said okay it's about trust it's about
freshness
but
this is only the name it's not only the
name how you build trust and you know
freshness and if you look at the domain
now there's revere aldi pure company
like there are many different names who
have been with their visuals with their
you know overall composure owning this
fresh and
trust and other things around around
supermarkets
and
if
today with a super bold model if you try
to own the same thing first of all
you're losing you're going into the
losing game it's a losing battle there
because
i mean i trust these guys and i wouldn't
trust
gorillas in the beginning so it's not
about trust basically
actually
at that point i began thinking
okay it's about values it's about who we
are and then i i begin thinking about
like who who are we what are we doing is
this is this a grocery company that
delivers things in 10 minutes is a bunch
of crazy people that get together and
you know try to rush
packets from a to b
not at all
so at our core at our core
we are about four things
we are authentic people
taking both decisions
owning the change and don't wait for the
change and always keep riding
so
these four people bold and authentic
is it get goodies
no man it's gorillas you know and so you
had the idea it was your name you like
you you you usually sat there and said
okay i'm going to call girls i was your
brainchild
yeah i mean it was my brainchild the
hardest part was to convince people that
it should be gorillas and i at the end
of that i didn't call this it like
realized because of the go i mean
there's go puff in the us which is like
also like a
game very similar game and did you like
want to have something with go in the
beginning or like how did you find it no
no no i mean not at all i would say it's
uh
these kind of things
they shaped later on
um
but we didn't we didn't we didn't think
about in the beginning get good this was
something like that that's okay there
should be goodies like maybe get and but
gorillas it was just
an outcome of the process that this
thought process that i just thought it's
bold authentic it's it can reflect our
values it can carry our values and it's
not grocery only
it's about doing things uh
unconventionally yeah
okay okay and so now the model i mean
how does the model work and why is why
is is this such a strong model i mean
how many people do you have today how
many employees uh today is it is a bit
more than 800 it's called getting close
to 100 1000 okay and how many warehouses
do you have today
today yeah
i don't know if one is open now like
we're launching one today uh 11
warehouses is what we have today across
three countries i agree across two
countries and i mean the plan for the
next couple weeks is to to ramp it up to
how many yeah so
so we are now fixing fixing certain
things uh so
like it looks like sunshine and rainbows
and
it's not like that so we fix we fix some
basics
um and we're almost there we're gonna
we're gonna have a new new app design
we're gonna have uh like much cooler
products uh we have
50 60 new locations coming up
and we have very cool very cool
campaigns uh like not campaigns but
actually
community building uh
projects i would say
so
we now prepare this and the moment we
prepare this we're just gonna in the q
one we're gonna go and
spread this to
50 60 other locations okay okay so now
explain the model a little bit why why
is it such a good model and what do
people don't see from the outside
man model is simply beautiful like it's
simply beautiful
it's not because it's 10 minutes by the
way it's not because you know why it's
beautiful
because it's so primitive the model is
actually
take awakes the
this primitive
primitive
uh emotions of people so
i tell you why so
can i tell you a little bit about like
more detail like what problem we solve
or do you really like specifics metrics
or okay so
if if you look at grocery space
it's one of the two primitive needs of
people yeah
and
so you so you need to stay somewhere
housing and you need to eat things
and
this is what this is a super big need
and that that's that's why also the
market is super big in europe is 2.6
trillion
globally it's 11 trillion blah blah blah
like but essentially people buy things
people do groceries for three main
reasons
so one is the emergency purchases you
know you know you cook panda raviata you
have the pasta pasta in water you need
the sauce how can you get it you need
that sauce
that moment but how can you get it
online delivery no i mean there's many
more value you cannot uh you know like
that you you there's the delivery
windows that i don't understand so one
third of the market is underserved this
emergency purchases
second third of the market is
replenishments
so basically
this is the use case you you go to your
kitchen
you open your fridge you look inside of
your fridge and at that moment at that
moment you want to grab something from
your fridge and that moment you realize
that the thing that you want to grab
from your fridge is not in your fridge
so you realize that oh man i want things
to appear here the need is super super
super emergent actually but what do you
do
you just close the fridge
you go to your living room so one third
another third of the market is
underserved
what we think is
the beauty of this model is not that uh
two thirds of the market is underserved
uh you know like
monday team yoga
yeah it's not that two-thirds of the
market is underserved but the bigger
problem is
the rest of this one-third of the market
weekly or
bad purchases is super served
all of the solutions
push people to order big amounts stock
in the warehouse and as a stock in their
houses
and you know carry this all of these
bags home
for me it's super counterintuitive
why yeah so
let's say that you and me philly panka
we go 20 000 years ago yeah 20 000 years
ago we're in a cave yeah
and you get hungry you get hungry and
you want to check the go back in the
cave and see if we have food just like
you go to your fridge
you go there you're hungry you check it
out there's no food
yeah there's no food
you're hungry you know you come you come
in front of the cave and you say come on
there's no food i don't know if you
speak by them but you draw it maybe so
so there's no food in the cave and
i think there's no caveman
ever existed that would give you this
answer
philip
don't don't worry
wait for saturday we don't go hunting
now we wait three four more days we go
for a bulk hunting with you back
gathering with you and then we eat on
saturday
we do
i understand the consumer proposition i
understand that that people want like
emergency purchases and then the desire
for for your service is there but then i
mean there's this the unit economics
question i mean how can it ever work if
somebody only orders an arabiata source
yeah that's like what is what does it
cost like our better source maybe like i
don't know four euros or something
exactly and then how can you make money
if you deliver this yeah perfect so
first of all
first of all
so let me let me let me finish what i
tell you and then it's going to connect
to this question okay so
what we what we believed what we believe
this if some one company pops up and
services emergency purchases like arabia
or the replenishments people would shift
their share of wallet more and more from
these big purchases to the middle ones
people wouldn't do big purchase but two
smaller but
you know like more frequent ones
and
in within these small purchases there
will be the arabiata source
but there will be also the
replenishments which is quite sizeable
you know arabiata's source is
199 in our store but replenishment is 50
60 euros sometimes more yeah so the
question is
where would it end up as every georgia
value coming to your question
um and
i think this is this the answer of this
question is this
imagine you do everything bulky
imagine a scale imagine a scale on one
side of the scale there's super bug
purchases you buy everything
that you need
that month
once yeah i'll find mine
and on the other side of the scale
you buy everything
alone you buy the sauce alone you buy
the yeah you know
water one bottle of water one banana one
banana like everything
buying
buying everything
are fine
once
in advance is not convenient
but also buying one by one is also not
convenient
so there is somewhere in between there
is a
possibility spot for convenience
that will shape things you know so
the question is where is this point
going to be so basically the question is
what's your average order value in the
long term yeah in the long term it's
going to be over 30 euros for sure i
mean now over 30 years do you think
and you see it already is it is it
already like is the shaping is shaping
is shaping towards that and shipping to
it so that so with 30 euro
value you can be profitable so you your
your
your
purchasing conditions are good enough so
you get enough
margin from buying the products so that
i mean basically right now at google's
the products cost the same as in
supermarket you don't have a you know
they're not very expensive
for for the customer right exactly no no
because it's enough it's enough like the
model is more efficient more the model
has
um you know less in-store costs
the model has
um you know less less in store cost is
like is a very big one actually so we
have less in store cost and this this
this is reflected to prices also we have
less waste that's that also
is reflected to fresh prices
okay but you have the other writer cost
yeah
i mean so
in hamburg yesterday so
yesterday yesterday in hamburg i did i
did two rides in 30 minutes so it's much
much less than much less than my berlin
average but i mean
so if you write yourself you can do like
five five deliveries in an hour yeah in
berlin i do five degrees and is that is
that like true for the most of your work
no no no not at all because man when i
move my bike
you get it fast
but like how much can you can you
average the delivery colleague
do yeah i mean this is this is this is
sense too but i can tell you you know
this is like a bedroom info so
so i mean i'm happy to tell you but
what i can tell you is
what i can tell you is
it's gonna
so i can compare it with the with the
food delivery a little bit for yeah
so what happens in food delivery first
of all
i mean you mean restaurant to the
restaurant that's right different
exactly
so
there are three things yeah your average
order value
your take rate
and
how many orders you do per hour
let's begin with the average order value
i might be wrong with these numbers
maybe develop but you know when i was
benchmarking
uh i was i was using these numbers so
the average order value is around 16 to
20 euros for me for four meal yeah so
this is what i and this is happening
with a minimum order value
um
so
on this on this on this uh average order
value you have 20 to 25 20 to 30 percent
take rates commissions from the
restaurants
and
if you're lucky
in a complete day
you do
somewhere between 1.8 to 2.2
rides per rider hour
and
demand distribution is super off you
know nothing happens people get hungry
in the lunch time huge peak nothing
happens or less things happen and after
that people get another people get
hungry again
in night
so
take this one and this one created that
mission impossible for for uh for
delivery companies food every companies
and put some competition on top and
increase the marketing cost you burn
like 10 to 15 euros per order
so this gave a so bitter taste to the
you know to the journalists
entrepreneurs and you know investors and
now there's a myth no delivery company
can make money
or can make i mean can make money is i
think actually a bad thing to say but
cannot build a sustainable change in the
domain
so
what happened after that in food
delivery
they wanted to so they wanted to say
okay we need to somehow find another
profit pools and what can we do we can
do ghost kitchens we can get into 30
profit pool extra profit pool of the
restaurants and we look at the data
build the right restaurant at the right
place just optimized for delivery and
then we take the 30 percent so then
those kitchens appeared
the beauty of our model is
we are ghost kitchens from the first day
because those warehouses warehouses yeah
so so we are not we are not replicating
something
if we would buy from the if we would go
and pick from the supermarket then we
would have we would have done the same
thing but
basically we are not doing that we own
our own inventory
and this this this makes us so you're
saying we have like uh
compared to to to to live ferando and
deliver hero in those companies you have
a better average order value yeah you
have a higher frequency per hour
definitely you know you have no peak
hours
or less less peak hours less peak hours
and you have better margins because you
don't have the restaurant margins you
can buy directly from the producer so
you're saying seeing your base i mean
and we're talking about companies that
are worth billions i mean lefrano is
worth billions and deliveries worth
billions yeah so you're saying like
basically
you found the better model and compared
to companies that are quite valuable i
didn't find the model
i didn't find the model
but i may like and but we are executing
very well in my point of view
so we we we haven't found the model so i
but
but we are doing something unique with
the model
and how many skus do you usually have i
mean what do you think
i mean how many products you're going to
have in the warehouse
i
we are now ramping it up
but it depends from market to market but
i mean in an average supermarket in a
river market there's probably like 20
000 products
yes
like
i mean it depends on the format but it's
from is from uh six thousand to forty
thousand you know like and then you're
gonna have them two to three thousand
but in this counters little for example
for a long time they had
how many 2 500 products max
but what i can tell you is what we try
to let me not give you some
some numbers because this is these
numbers are you know
uh confidential not confidential they're
changing yeah it's changing constantly i
mean today for example there's a big
change in number of skills so but
anyways
we look at a couple of things so
in london for example
average person
buys 220 different products
in a year in a year 220 different
products from a supermarket
in supermarkets with 60 000 products
yeah
but
no two people by the same buys the same
in 2020.
so what we try to do here is
how can we create a
the five percent of this how can we
select this five percent of the world in
terms of goods
so that
we
a
promote
living more with less
yeah more convenience with less
consumption like less amount of
consumption and b
is
create a super efficient model so
this is basically what we try to do with
our assortment and we ramp it up we ramp
ramp this number up
until we cover the essential needs
minimize of sevdesk sfo desk
the landing page self-des point a slash
omr medium code omr 900
there's rumors in the market that that
that
it is possible for you to like have like
a more than 100 million in revenue in
2021 is that possible
uh
definitely
you mean monthly
no i mean yeah
i mean really i mean
so you mean december or you mean hold on
i mean i mean 2021 this year like do you
think you can crack 100 million revenue
already
i mean definitely a year
okay so so you're already but but it's
not a revenue game
it's a it's a margin game so
so it's not a it's not a business that
has uh that has 30 so like revenue is a
misleading misleading uh metric here
because revenue grows
much faster than probably
you imagine so um
the key thing is
is there a clear road to profitability
one question and second is uh of course
how you
create a community you know how you how
you
create a community that's uh that's
building this with you in terms of i
mean i mean consumers but is it is it
focused on big cities only can it only
happen in hamburg and berlin and cologne
okay i mean flash and past they started
in munster small city
do you see a business also happening in
munster or a similar city uh
so
we are analyzing it we have a big data
tool that shows this and like we
identified we identified
many locations on on small on small
cities but we are not
first first we want to cover the big
cities
because as we cover the big cities we
are we're learning every single day we
are still in this process of
learning and optimizing the model and
when when optimized model will work in
smaller cities
okay okay so so you're thinking small
cities can at some point also be on the
roadmap yes yes yes i mean
at some point yes
okay and you're active right now in
germany which cities are you working
so
at the end of q1 yeah at the end of q1
we will we will cover um
the most dance the most tense seven
cities
in in germany but in the end i mean do
you think about a city or do you think
about a neighborhood i mean i know that
in hamburg we talked about this for the
podcast you have three different
warehouses to surf like in hamburg the
chance and winter
and altona right so it's it's like you
think in neighborhoods yeah i'm thinking
yeah thinking neighborhoods and like i
would say like 80 percent of the
of the
inner city population will be covered
let's put it this way eighty percent of
the inner city population and
and okay right now you have 11
warehouses yeah and then there's one one
is in cologne couple is berlin
three three colon one hamburg
six
uh
six in
six seventh we i don't know if you're
live yet with it but 7 let's say 7 in
berlin
it's already 11 and we have uh now one
in amsterdam
and why amsterdam huh why amsterdam i
love amsterdam
so um
but i'm not kidding i mean
we as a company like we really believe
doing businesses in place that we love
uh
so
and
i don't know if it's a course this but
data always tells the tells uh that's a
similar result so what did you look at i
mean what do you look at when you open a
city i mean so
first of all
i go there person and bike yeah so i go
there personally bike you know look at
look at uh look at the people talk to
people
um
and
and then and then take and take an
airbnb you know like take an airbnb in
the district that i want to open and
do you want to open and then order some
some groceries with the current methods
you know you
what then you understand more or less
what's happening then you understand
that you need to stay in either you need
to
either you have a good option or not
so in amsterdam
you know why i think the biggest
penetration
thing will be the stairs man the stairs
man they're so narrow they're so narrow
like it feels like it feels like
climbing you know it's like a temple in
in mexico you know they have this temple
so
is it so narrow and so steep i think
this is so you you understand these kind
of small details uh when
you listen can you can you notice like
that
most of your
customers live like in higher yeah
exactly is it true i mean yeah fourth
fifth floor um because this extra value
if you're in the first floor you wanna
go you know but if you're on the fourth
fifth floor
you want to get
so this is i think the amsterdam many
people live
like high up no uh no but they have
stairs
you know stay nice but i mean they're
just like give me the metrics i mean i
understand this this is very anecdotal
and very interesting i mean but i'm sure
you're like also looking at like yeah i
know i know we do we have we have a big
data tool that tells us open there yeah
so
but based on what yeah so many things
man many things so
population density
early adopter rate
uh
discounted penetration um supermarket
penetration you know like we have we
have third wave third wave uh coffee
shop penetration scooter pantry we have
many things and food delivery
penetration
but
not
i mean interestingly not always we
usually we use it as a correlation for
example food delivery penetration and
for example berlin i mean we chose
berlin because there's inverse
correlation between food delivery and uh
food we believe there's inverse
correlation between food daily
penetration and
what do you mean by that yeah
i mean
maybe maybe i formulate in the wrong way
but what i think is
you let's say that we do this in berlin
yeah we do this in berlin and in berlin
we don't have the most most advanced
food delivery
system you know like or convenience
convenience culture so
there are
so that's why if you want to eat
something
if you want to eat something you need to
wait a little bit now vault is slowly
changing that
but it's not it's not really well
covered
compared to other capitals and
in supermarkets also there's no there's
no good solution there's no good
solution there's no ocado there's no you
know solution that directly brings it to
you
so that's why
what we do here is is perceive the
incremental value of what we do here
perceived as
super high what i mean by that is it
feels like
getting a solution from 90s to 2030 and
this craze like wow like it's a wow
effect
but
well we like which which creates a
good viral effect around around the
business but if you go to london for
example yeah
amsterdam is also one of the one of one
of the
landscapes like this
so
the like the
digital solutions are so so advanced you
know like are so convenient
that the incremental value that you
bring is not from 90s to 2030s but it's
more like 20s to 30s in amsterdam or
like in amsterdam yeah
so
in my point of view
then you just say okay
10 minutes delivery it's good it's
another solution you know it's not like
wow man this time because you're saying
that the wow effect is bigger in berlin
than in amsterdam
it's going to be like that in my point
of view it's going to be like that in in
my in markets that has
lower levels of uh this is just a
hypothesis it might be completely wrong
but so you're saying like most german
cities are like in the 90s in terms of
food delivery and
like foreign or like international
cities some of them are already like
more advanced you have more convenience
there and so google is not going to make
such a big difference yeah i don't want
to say it's this it's not it's nine it's
90s but
especially after the delivery
wars you know like it wasn't like that
for two years ago because they were like
the rule fedora uh you know the ferrando
but then once they get out
there there was a big gap of
there was a big big gap of uh
convenience for a long time for a long
time there was only different there
uh
and compared to other capitals this was
one of the only capitals that i've been
and i i see only you know one player
taking uh
taking the market you know
how many how many um customers do you
have
like
roughly yeah
yeah what i can say is
in our delivery so we don't let me not
tell the numbers um
exactly but
but it's more than fifty
uh thousand yeah yeah it's more than
that yeah yeah more than that is that
but it's is it already six digit
it's getting there it's gonna be there
like once we open once we open
first of all not customers so i want to
i won't tell this you know like i'm
we're cheaper into metrics but
so
we don't
we don't really treat this okay
customers crm discount code
like is like more more more more more is
like we don't do that so
at the moment what we do is and we don't
we don't care so much about number of
customers philip so what we care about
is
exactly but a couple of but a couple of
things not repurchasing like this is one
metric we do but what we would try to do
is
we believe that
we believe that
if you're going to the moon yeah you
shouldn't go to the supermarket man if
you have this technology you should have
you should have a more techy approach to
to do this you know you can go to moon
like imagine this you we go to the space
if this is something this for me
something you know
so yeah something incredible
but if we have this technology
why the like why my most primitive need
doesn't come come to my my home you know
so
so this is a significant change so this
is not something incremental in my point
of view because this
this there are huge industries around
this most primitive need and to move
this
we need a
we need values we need values and a
community that shares these values and
we need to share these values to the
community
and
that's why
number of customers
is a misleading metric
number of like size of the community and
community meaning that number of people
that we went to their doors and
explained our vision explained what we
tried to change explain who we are is
the real metric and that's coming that's
that comes with retention that comes
with exactly retention how like um
what
that i mean of course there's service
levels attached to it but
retention is also about you know like if
you're if you have
buy into the vision of the company so
how do you advertise i mean you the
first i understand first customers you
you gained them because they were your
neighbors and you threw the the flyers
into their mailboxes and and today i
mean is it like
all word-of-mouth i mean i see that you
do some like app store advertising but
but how do you advertise
i mean we have a fancy name for it
inside we call it viral growth loop
design viral growth loop design yeah um
so this this basically
is something that we
begin exploring and thinking about
because we began in full constraints
yeah and what i mean by that we had zero
zero cap zero uh budget for marketing
for a long time
and
we said okay
i mean how can we design
free
touch points
that will
take our values
and
reflect to what we do
and
so
this is this is the approach we do and
and touchpoint what i mean is like every
touch point that we have the customer we
have it the customer is a is a touch is
a it can be a different channel it can
be facebook it can be youtube it can be
you know a postcard it can be our uh our
bike crew on the street you know many
touch points so we design
this wild growth loop how do we do it we
do three things
we give our community first of all
we give our community
something they have to talk about
something that they would be super
amazed i mean there's no way that you
don't talk about it yeah it's one thing
second thing is
we
tell them
how it's best for us
for them to talk about it
and then third one we talked about
so
just to give an example
i don't think tammy theory is
worth to talk i mean you can talk about
it but 10 minutes it's not not
impressive enough yeah i mean it's
impressive it's impressive
but
two minute daily is more impressive
i mean two minutes you order two minutes
bomb you have to talk about it yeah
yeah how can you create
so viral growth loop has to meet
delivery for example but how is it
possible i mean you can't be in two
minutes at somebody's door
you can be upstairs you can do
upstairs is you upstairs of the
warehouse you can do
okay so so you know this you know this
concept of don't have 1000 customers
don't have 100 000 customers that love
you but have like that
don't have 100 000 customers but
have
100 people community that really loves
you this is what this is what this i
what we believe is is
we are proud of building and that that's
the base of why things are going viral
so and
and the fundamentals of this reality is
these three things two minutes delivery
i tell two three minutes
um
and so it's not classic advertising but
so at some point would there be like
people like riding the bikes in costumes
or will they be like gorillaz costumes
or what is it going to be like
i i write myself sometimes with costumes
and i sometimes walk in costumes
but can you skate i mean you can't scale
that i mean no i can't scale it and i
don't want to scale that because
because what i realized this some babies
are getting scared
man i walk sometimes you know like i'm
super happy inside of the costume but uh
babies
you're not doing it i mean it's super
viral like people people like it um and
but we will stop it because babies care
i don't like that okay so okay
even
faster delivery times than 10 minutes is
impressive what else is impressive
my values sticking to values is
impressive authenticity is impressive if
you don't you don't say cigarettes is
that also like because of your values
yeah yeah i mean
this this is more of a technical thing
than our values
so our values is four things and uh
so i i repeat this over and over again
but tell me if i pre too much because
like we because
my job what i do now is i repeat these
values when i repeat it to at all time
all parts of like all my teammates you
know so
authentic people we are authentic people
we take bold decisions
we always
own the change and always keep i mean
how are you going to bring it to the
next level i mean i understand that i
mean i i i know you so i can totally
trust that you have these values but i
mean if you hire a rider yeah
in the end he has to like also carry
that and also you have to escape i mean
it's how can you get this into amsterdam
and
and make it a business you mean the
values yeah yeah super easy so
because it's a priority yeah so because
it's a priority i say time on this
because i mean
our first of all
it begins it begins from me yeah i in
the fundraising part in the fundraising
part one of our uh
coming to your marketing question 20 25
of the traffic is generated by uh flashy
colors you know
flashy colors on on on the branding you
know like uh you have pink you have uh
you know orange yeah
i'm not comfortable in these colors
and in my vision is to change how riding
is perceived i'm i lived on my bike six
months yeah and i want how i want to
change how writing is perceived how can
you do this
two things you have a legal base and
find a comfortable legal and financial
base for our bike crew and you make them
proud on the bike
so then it's not a gig they don't take
they don't take the back from a to b
but
they're on their own a vision to change
how riding is perceived
so within within this within this region
when we we had zero money we had zero
money we were raising funds and
one if one one of the investors
came in and
you need to have a flash color you need
to have like billboards like this is
like they like the fedora and delivery
they have cool they have cool colors but
um you can do it in a cool way but you
have to have flashcard
we didn't have we didn't have
you know mine to invest in at that
moment i said look man
we
we can grow slower we can grow slower we
don't care but my bike crew
will be
proud on their bikes and i'm not proud
when i have the flashy color
so i like all black i like all black i
want to have i want to have the nicest
equipment you know like i want to go the
last logo looks like the supreme logo
yeah yeah like i want to be proud i
don't want i'm not some my my bike crew
is not a bike crew that's a billboard my
we are not billboards man if we grow
less we grow less
i mean
and if you don't want to invest because
don't [ __ ] invest in me you know so
so this is this is this is basically how
we house
and and we had 100 euros in the bank
account while while i'm saying this and
it was like you know
but can i come to your question so how
can you scale this to amsterdam how can
you scale those other countries
we
religiously
give the meaning why we exist and i i
tell you like i tell you i tell you how
you can exist there's only way to scale
this is to
really understand
what's what's the purpose of the
business
and
is our purpose groceries is our purpose
10 minutes deliveries it's not
this the scaling of it like this
vibrant momentum around the business is
not about to be delivered in 10 minutes
or we deliver in 15 minutes or seven
minutes
it's about
a company popped in popped out
and with these four values
we create a
we created a magnetic connection with
with our community
not because we delivered the groceries
because because we inspired we
inspired this community
to
interact with the world differently
they don't ask oh
how how fast is this they so they ask
you how did you do it you know they they
they're inspired because like
they realized there was so primitive
need that they have and we showed them
so this is this is this is what we're
this is how we scale it then let me just
let me just come back with a very
technical marketing question
like with the percentage of your
marketing expenses is that like five
percent or like two percent or ten
percent of your revenue like what do you
think what do you what do you expect
there
uh just tell me let me tell you the
right answer it's it's around one and a
half percent more than a half percent is
paid marketing so it's it's not very
important yeah
okay so it's viral is important
viral is much more important than paid
market
and then
maybe back to the model i
mean what you see with it with them
flashing posts and others is that they
i think long term will make money by
charging
um
the producers of those of their products
to be like in a very special place in
the app so you you you basically have a
media model where like amazon where you
where
your companies that that you deliver
they can pay for very good location or
very good
[Music]
presentation in your app
and then you get like media intake media
revenues that are very profitable is
that
already happening
that was gonna happen
but we didn't want it to happen because
like it was a very big corporation and
uh we didn't know if it was the right
thing to do because
yeah so you got approached by like a big
supermarket
like a cpg company cpg com and they want
to like give you money so you present
their products in a better place in the
app yeah yeah but you don't believe in
that
i mean they wanted us to display it in
gorilla's fave man
god last fave is not packaged products
is it faves is it like a certain tab in
the app where you have products that you
like personally
yeah
but you know it's
i this is just bananas for us you know
we are gorillas and you know what we
like is bananas so that's why in gurla's
way we have bananas and they want their
product to be there as well
yeah man but
i mean do you see this business
happening at some point
i see it i see it happening i see it
happening but it should happen our way i
mean just because a couple of cents we
don't do it okay so somebody has to
spend big and then he'll be like a nice
place in the app no no
just because a couple of cents we
wouldn't change our faves okay so but
you can like do other things you can
like yeah somebody clicks on on
beverages you can be the first beverage
or you can be the the tent yeah we're
going to do it and we're going to do it
the right way we're not going to do it
in a way that we put something to our
gorgeous face if it's not our faith okay
okay okay what's the most purchased
product
bananas seriously
but my house is amazing you know but i
mean is that i mean it's not an
emergency product i mean who's who's
like cooking needs a banana man banana
is something amazing it's like imagine
this tell me one other fruit
that that's so tasty and you can access
so easily you know you know you buy it
but
you're not lying i mean seriously banana
is the most broad product
yes
but but
every time you buy banana you don't buy
one so you buy multiple and you buy
units so maybe if you divide it into
units
it's different but banana is the biggest
one and the second one
yeah this is uh i mean i don't know if i
should tell this but
but it's it's about fruits and veggies
man
so the most the single most important
category is fruits and veggies i mean
yeah it's important category because
it's fresh stuff it's fresh stuff i mean
obviously it's fresh stuff is what you
need within 10 minutes i mean the other
stuff you can usually wait yeah i can
tell you a little bit about like why why
fresh stuff are uh
mo selling a bit more than the fair
share in supermarket maybe so basically
one question how can you buy blueberries
on saturday
and still eat on wednesday
it's it's almost impossible it goes
moldy it goes not fresh so this mo like
gorillas what what we do is
we
help
we help people to
you know access with access
access fresh items
and eat consume them when they're fresh
so this is this is super beautiful part
of the model and that's why we see
we see a lot of fresh consumption or low
shelf life consumption in the in the
model and and if you think about this uh
philip this is the consumer side
what do you do as a cpg company
you know like a big packaged goods
company to survive in a in the current
current structure of the retail
so basically what you do is you maximize
your shelf life and how you maximize
your shelf life
you take
something you put in a plastic bag
you put some chemicals inside and you
make something naturally something
something something you know
in unnatural
and if this not if but when we penetrate
when we get get more and more when we
increase our community
we will not only
we will not only build this around
around the iran to around the consumer
we will also change
the
food industry around it like this is
like our gran in our grand vision so
we really see we really see i mean
decreasing the number of food industry
is broken
documentaries in netflix or something
you know it's it's totally doable with
this model it's just it's amazing it's
beautiful it's beautiful model
and i mean
grand plans i mean changing the food
industry for the better obviously i mean
you're delivering by bike there's so
many aspects and you have less waste
right and then and i mean
now that there's there's like big time
investors believing in this like a
couple weeks ago it came out that you
had a
44 million
invested in the company
um by i think it's an american company
um and so if they gave you 44 million to
expand
so usually like when you have that it's
not a big it's not a big
mystery your company is already worth
like 200 million now i mean that's
usually how it works i mean it's that's
everybody knows that i mean you get 40
million you don't give away the whole
company so usually give you weight like
20 percent so you're already at this
point right i mean it's amazing after
like eight well how does it now like 16
months from from zero to like
possibly 20 million i mean
yeah first of all co2 led the round yeah
so so it's it's just correct this is
they led the round not the whole amount
is from them coming from co2 and uh
and we're very lucky to
uh you know
partner with them i mean they're they're
not only
providing capital also a lot of good
connections
uh and many more also brain power
extension how did you find them three
three angels or three uh uh yeah um
you know you know uh shoko
yeah yeah the the also like very
interesting
ceo uh uh daniel introduced me okay okay
sure
and is is that gonna be the the is there
a new round coming in 2021 you think
i mean uh
it could be
yeah i mean you're gonna you're not
gonna change the food industry with only
45 million in the bank
i mean the question is how can you how
can you
how can you exactly how can you change
how can you change it and you for change
is you need unit capital in the
beginning and at the moment we need
capital uh we have access to capital so
but i mean
if i like spin this further is it i mean
it could be a story where you're like
from founding the company
and then two years later could you be a
unicorn by then
like a billion dollar company i mean the
next funding round you're not going to
be at 20 million you're probably going
to ask for like a valuation of 500 600
million at least i would say
yeah philip
it might sound cheesy but i have no
connection with the size of the business
or like the valuation or like you know
like it's
at the end of the day it
it's all about change all about the
change and if the change requires money
we dilute as a company if
the change doesn't require money we
don't raise money so the key thing is
why we're doing it and how much capital
we need for it and do we have access
to it so we know why we do it we know
how much we require and we have access
to capital and
so you become a unicorn you don't become
a unicorn it's going to be much much
earlier than two
24 months
it's like this model is is like if if we
keep on doing if we keep on doing
how we do things and stick to our values
as a company and as you mentioned if we
can
preserve this at this pace of growth
then uh
then basically capital is not it's not
the bottleneck
it's we just you know we just spread
this uh so you're saying then you'll be
a unicorn like in less than 24 months
i mean
if as i said if it if if we stick to our
values it's a matter of uh
it's not a matter of
years it's a matter of months
okay okay and i mean there's a lot of
clones now popping up everybody's seen
like what you build there like
the digital industry is very transparent
people like look at where money goes and
how many other like
delivery like express delivery companies
are in germany like popping up right now
how many exist would you would you guess
i mean in german i i don't i i'm not i
don't want to tell number in germany but
i i can tell you a total number of
london germany and uh and um paris
so there are there are 12
there are 12
12 different teams working on this
um
and two and twelve
actually to have good teams you know
they're good teams
um do 12 good teams working on this and
it's gonna be it's gonna be a
competitive market for sure it's gonna
be a competitive market
what i
what i don't like is what i don't like
is
some of these teams
yeah not all some of these teams
they do
to one
you know
i mean
delivery area one to one go to the real
estate guy tell them we are gorillaz
colon one two one one two one like
i mean this is like some of these people
also not not with gorillas also fruit
gopal there's also one player now that's
exactly go like
you know maybe it's even go puff i don't
know like so similar
so
what i don't like is
the beauty of the domain
can be damaged by this
not by authentic people trying to do
this
like i'm super like i i love it i love a
good team you know like doing something
vt you know like challenging i love that
i want i want to be in that kind of a
setup but i mean come on i mean have
some values and reflect to what you do
because why i say this man europe
is an amazing place
for especially coming from coming from
you know turkey like we love our country
but we we we look at the know-how and
the accumulation of knowledge in this co
in this continent yeah
so
there's a lot of good entrepreneurs
there's a lot of uh you know like good
good works
art
love it yeah
but
as
in this setup in this setup there's also
a lot of cloning happening
like in in a setup where you have where
you're this amazing thing so you're
saying if there's a clone people don't
have the same passion as you they might
ruin the whole
domain what i say is what i say is i
think this is what's going to happen
for example
what happened in retail industry like
we're gonna we're gonna repeat the
history i think with this model with
this with this cloning and i don't like
that's why that's why that's why i want
to scale as as as long as we're proud
you know what of what we're doing so
what happened in retail uh
grocery retail first there were small
kiosks milkman
you know bakery and at some point
they
they begin getting together and they
increase their assortment in their in
these local shops and
and these local shops became more
expensive to be
to be in the in the
in the local place and also they need
more space so that's why
there's a
there are hyper markets and supermarkets
being emerged
outside of the city
so people were going there as an
experience you know like ah like we take
the families saturday we go
as time goes
people
began living much more fast paced and
time became the scarce resource and then
like less and less
the the number of people that's going
outside of the city decreased and that's
why the uh the grocery companies they
they decree this decrease the format and
opened small mini formats within the
city
and
during this during this time
what happened is
if there's one supermarket next next
door next corner you have the other
supermarket
and at some point everything became
equal in these markets
and
and what happened price war began
so
so so what happened is we basically lost
this touch
and we began competing
and
competition is healthy i like
competition you know i'm i'm national
level water polo player i cry when i
when i'm the water and you know when i'm
winning and losing you know i'm i'm
i love if there's one someone to compete
i'm i'm the one who's who wants to
compete
but
if it's
for the sake of what
i mean if if it's a construct
constructive competition that takes the
level up it's okay but i mean
the approach of
they make money we don't let's
let's clone
i mean this is this is i think this i
think i think europe deserves better
than this coming from looking europe as
an idle continent
i think i came here with a with a
different with a different uh
perspective to be honest
and uh and this is i'm not gonna let
this happen man i'm not i'm i'm not
gonna let this domain to be dirty i love
this so much
and my team
my team loves this so much it's not
about me it's like this young ambitious
and authentic people like constantly
pushing for both decisions
always riding you know being a one team
like these people
they deserve to spread this change in
them
in a non-destructive way and that's why
they're coming to your question uh
this can be a unicorn i don't care about
unicorn
but
i'm gonna
i'm gonna i feel responsible for for my
team
uh to
don't spend so much time with
competition we just win and move forward
so
because we have a lot of things to do
around our vision and we want to we want
to do this we want to you know apply
this vision
in a in a very clean way in a very
transformative way in a very in a very
mindful and respectful way
so
yeah we want to change we want to create
a healthy community okay okay okay
it's an amazing story i mean
no matter the valuation no matter the
exact revenue right now but i mean
you've like within
a couple months uh you've like
transformed your own life now you're
like a
founder that vcs want to talk to
probably actually companies want to
approach i'm assuming like you get like
inbound interest all the time people
like i want to invest in you
and uh
you know a couple months ago you were
like walking around in berlin and uh you
know cutting your own flyers and
and
i mean sometimes it feels like a dream
for you probably right
to be honest i still feel like i'm
cutting my flyers i mean i it's not like
a it's not like a dream so for example
now that i i talk to you now
it feels weird i mean it feels weird i
want to go back to my uh you know our
warehouse
and talk to anton you know last time i
saw him it was september and he came
here and built an amazing team you know
like he's he just graduated last year i
want to congratulate them and you know
like do a couple of rides with them so
at the moment
we are tour too far away from talking
about
being in a dream state we are we are
executing all in
and
and we don't feel like we established
something so we esta only thing that
we're proud of two things we establish a
really like very really good team super
connected
with you know cohesive cohesive you know
cohesive team
and
we have a really good community we have
a really good community of
uh what what what's your talk i mean how
old is your average buyer
our average buyer yeah now it changed a
lot now the spread went to 55 to 60s but
in the beginning there was an early
adopter uh you know classical adapter
age range
25 to 35. oh okay so but now it's like
elderly people that oh
yeah yeah yeah now
not not not elderly but you know like
it's
man come on very soon we are 55 you
shouldn't say elderly yeah
okay and then and okay and and
do you feel like this the classic
supermarkets are going to be a threat to
you as well i mean the clones are there
then
obviously flushing post has a different
model and picnic those guys were on the
podcast they they have different models
it takes like different delivery windows
like
you know days later so it's different
right now at least you feel like like a
river online and those guys threatening
you
i mean they're solving a different
problem
so
i think they are different solving a
different problem so that's why i don't
i don't see them as a threat
because
as i told you
you're in a cave
you know you're in a cave and there's no
food in the back in the cave
and
you know
we
immediately go and
go go for hunting together philip and
they just say that okay wait wait we go
saturday so uh i don't believe that this
is the threat but what i think is a
threat is
this this model is so beautiful that
you know like
people will underestimate and will try
to try to inject capital into this
and well the moment they inject
they they will like the industry might
go into a very wrong every very very
wrong side they will try to buy
people not create the community is it
possible i mean
i know you a little bit now we talked a
couple hours before the podcast or
almost
you have access to so many cell phones
now and it's growing i mean you have
like i don't know 100 000 cell phones
they have a gorilla's app now maybe more
um
and certainly more in the coming months
and years
and you say it's not about groceries
necessarily i mean can you imagine like
using this reach and using this
community as you call it yeah
to to sell and deliver something
completely away from groceries yes yes
so
i mean
i tell you i tell you how we think and
you know i
and then
you can cut after the after the podcast
if you want if it's too detailed
so
because once i want to tell this and so
that everything sticks yeah as i said
these four things that i mentioned the
four values
gives us a purpose that we want to
change
how the world interacts with
their essential needs yeah
we just want to change this
and
what we believe is
the moment we
give
immediate access to the essential needs
of of of of people
they will begin consuming more mindfully
and respectfully
this is just this example of you know uh
if like the billionaires
don't have this you know like
you know golden uh suits and stuff you
know so they because once you once once
you get rid of the scarcity in your life
you're more mindful because you know you
can access and you access more mindfully
so
to do this our mission
is to create the
fastest infrastructure that gives gives
people
the
the essential needs
and a community to check spread this so
around this
around essential needs what are
essential needs
grocery is one of the essential needs
yeah
peace of mind is for us is an essential
need
so for example peace of mind
grocery we're covering
peace of mind
how do i get my peace of mind sometimes
i think about it i do meditation
so sometimes work sometimes i get you
know
i distract get distracted but i do
meditation i do sports i educate myself
i read
so these
are for us these are essential needs
so
around around this spectrum
coming to your question
one way once we have once we have many
um
you know many phone like many many
phones or access to the pockets
i think
i think
we shouldn't think about like uh just
going to the physical and physical space
that can make us additional
additional physical revenue but we
should also think about
uh
for example
how can we how can we give this peace of
mind can we give a 10-minute meditation
yeah to rule the gordhas up yeah can we
can we uh
i mean we have many ideas when we have
many ideas around this um so the
goalless app at some point will
definitely be more than just a foot
delivery app yeah yeah i mean the the
financial decision is go to apoteca you
know go otc medication this is the
financial decision where you should go
to expand your market yeah
coming to your case because when you
look at the surveys it says that
i don't do that there's a survey from
mckinsey it says i don't do that that
because of long delivery times on you
know they don't do online shopping
because of long term times 27
groceries 26 percent uh
medication pharmacy and the rest is
eight nine percent so you so you have to
conquer this market as well
i mean the
the idea also ideal
you know ideal path is that one
uh
but
as i said is this our values
we are around
like is this our is our value so
maybe maybe there's a
there's a better solution for us maybe
for us uh maybe for us
meditation is a better solution than
uh than oppotek
okay khan that was there was
many many different storylines
very interesting situations we
definitely want to follow your story in
the next um
month and years and it's i'm sure you'll
like create more waves in the in the
industry here in germany and maybe in
europe um thank you so much for coming
by
yeah thank you very much for inviting me
man like it was a super nice room with a
super nice vibe that you created
so
i really i really thank you uh for for
you know calling me i quite enjoyed it
and one thing before uh one thing before
we close maybe um i just want to send
one thank you yeah uh
like nine months ago actually i was
listening to your podcast so it's not
that you know like
i was listening and i was saying okay
like
one day you know i'm gonna talk about
the vision and what we're doing and
everything and
i think
if if i'm doing this now it's just is is
purely is purely about this the two
things you know the the team that's
super united
and
the community that supports our uh
vision so i want to take and also like
the uh you know like the combination of
both i want to thank both for uh
for my internal team and i don't want to
say external team but also the external
community i'm super thankful man like
we're gonna change this together for
sure i'm super pumped up for this
i love it
thank you very much cheers
bye-bye
newsletter
my necklace
slash newsletter
these are podcasts
from podstars
by om air